mit diesem mini u boot will e.on musk
bei der rettung der eingeschlossenen
jungen in thailand helfen
der us-milliardär twitterte am sonntag
ein video das zeigt wie zwei taucher das
gerät durch eine engstelle passieren
in der kapsel ist platz für eine person
musk hatte bereits am samstag mitgeteilt
dass ein team seines privaten
raumfahrtunternehmen spacex an einem
mini tauchboot arbeite für den bau werde
man acht stunden brauchen und witterte
maske 17 weitere stunden seien für den
transport nach thailand nötig bereits in
dem asiatischen land eingetroffen sind
diese aufblasbaren rettungskapseln die
die kalifornische firma inflatables in
zusammenarbeit mit spacex entwickelt hat
ob die so genannten e skateboards aber
auch wirklich bei der bergung der seit
mehr als zwei wochen festsetzen den
jugendfußball mannschaft zum einsatz
kommen ist bislang unklar
unterdessen wurden die rettungsarbeiten
an der tam long höhle am montagvormittag
fortgesetzt
am sonntag waren vier jungen von
rettungstauchern begleitet in sicherheit
gebracht worden
es gehe ihnen gut teilte der
einsatzleiter am montag mit aus sorge
vor möglichen infektionen dürften sie
jedoch noch nicht zu ihren eltern
acht weitere kinder und ihr
fußballtrainer sitzen noch in der grotte
fest der einsatz hier bilder vom samstag
ist riskant und langwierig die taucher
müssen durch eine überflutete hohen
gänge am vergangenen freitag war ein
ehemaliger taucher der spezialeinheit
teilnehmer seals in der höhle tödlich
verunglückt